have you had any ask
acting to me as a complete mystery
because what actors are doing especially
they're working with something that they
don't see you know the advantage that i
have this director is that i'm always
looking at what I'm actually trying to
to manipulate or do you know cop out and
I don't know how actors are doing it you
know that they are portraying something
with their face with their bodies and
judge it without actually seeing I could
never do that I don't know how how they
do it so I never had any terrified to
actually be
Blair to stay behind the camera with
with necessary death we had me after all
the camera twice just to say this board
was important to me is that I could
actually asked questions from behind the
camera and kind of steer the scene and
that we could have that in the movie so
you do have the German accent behind the
camera yeah and then we just want to
give that a body and say this is
actually the guy then i'll let that
voice belongs to so that we don't have
that mystery that ? mmm i wonder what
the guy behind the camera moves right
but for the audience to just relax and
get that out of there hence this one guy
looks like now let's focus on the story
again
at that point also because I love being
in turn off the camera so much
what about when you hear from other
filmmakers that they're secretly scared
doctors I have
actors in work with
in a sense of being afraid to direct
them in a certain way or just being
afraid of the fact that there's such
emotional creatures and
they're very sensitive
sometimes very insecure as sort of the
nature of the business makes you that
way so then you're more afraid of the
extra act or going insane kind of unset
it you can catch them or something like
that
us times I think we've heard from some
directors that they have been
intimidated by actors to work with them
or maybe just intimidated to sort of
take direction and steer the ship it's a
very sort of
you have to have strong you go to do it
scary so I picked events under style
because in film school and when I came
out of film school I had the same
feeling that the directors require to
have a vision that he has to have the
movie in his head and I didn't and it
was like my little shameful secret that
I really didn't have a vision and I
couldn't i didn't have everything
pre-visualized and I didn't have the
storyboard in my head I always had to
see you before it happened which I think
when actors really helped me because I
was kind of open to takes because I
didn't have a premeditated take in my
head and then if you don't actually have
that if you don't try to to make the
actor be your vision that you try to
figure out something that feels
emotionally true and challenging and
inspired together with the actor then I
don't know if there's anything to be
afraid of other than that the actor
play with should be to be experiment
experimented enough that's really all I
need from actors that he's willing to
first of all let them to go I think the
one thing that kills Hector's is vanity
because then they are not able to
actually get to the moments that are
most interested and with my last film
Ashley Bell was the most incredible
actress I ever seen when I she would get
excited we had a shot that is shooting
up for nostrils and they're like all
slimy and stuff she would love that
because it's so real you know she would
get excited when I know a lot of actress
that would actually say over my dead
body are we using that shot you know but
that just tells me that they are not
completely in that character because
obviously the character and that goes
back to to breaking the character you
want to get the character to the point
where they're not looking good anymore
and the hair is not perfect calm anymore
and you know the makeup isn't perfect
anymore
for the question
intimidating fellow actors and what do
you say to other filmmakers who maybe
are hesitant they're scared they
secretly won't admit it
young to me someone said that in an
acting class I think was jus dat Weston
that what inspires actors most is if the
director says I don't know or that
relaxes actors because Hector's unjust
it's on my theory better oh she's a hell
but actors are so tense because they're
nervous because they're insecure they
can give the director what the director
wants so the second of the director says
I don't actually have a preconceived
notion about this let's just play and
see what we come up with suddenly that
pressure is gone you know and suddenly
you are putting yourself on the same
level with the actor which does relax
the actor but it also will excess
meaning if I don't have that vision I
don't have that perfectly felt out thing
you know and just open about it and then
there's really nothing to be scared of
anymore cuz you are sittin on the same
boat it'd be different if the actor gets
uncomfortable because you don't have a
vision of the actor once
you always hear actors and interviews
that say all that our director was great
he knew exactly what he wanted you know
and I'm sure there are directors like
that it's just not doing me any good to
fake that I'm one of those directors I'm
just not Marlowe's director and I think
there is a way to make movies that a
really interesting and inspiring not
being one of those times because
suddenly you're inviting the talent of
the group in to kind of form what you're
doing and you still are the one who put
that tea together and the characters
together with an elephant technique of
who they really are but then you have to
give them the freedom to actually have
input and then get really excited
because they are not used to it because
I think a lot of directors do this whole
I have a vision whether it's pretense or
not you know that they have a vision so
it doesn't leave a lot of room to the
actors to actually make their own
decision make suggestions and bring in
their own creativity you know they're
just trying to execute what they think
that our entrance but if you invite them
to play and to create it suddenly
inspires a completely different part of
their brain you know
I think in the best version of that you
end up with a product that feels rich
because it's it's coming from a lot of
different personalities and a lot of
different minds and it's not just all
filled up through my tiny mind and
worldview you know because then every
character fields like it's been written
by one mind and I think you can feel
that like if you Aaron Sorkin where
things want the greatest writers in the
world but every single character you can
feel is written by aaron sorkin there's
a certain appeal so that's one way to go
I think with necessary death for example
what we were trying to do is to have
every single character have their own
voice and make it seem like real life
and not as if it's filtered through one
moment
you